our application 1801 four five six full
the elms 14 High Street Henley and Arden
and if I can ask Charlotte Dix the case
officer to talk about that Thank You
chairman the sighted indicated on the
map by the black circle the application
site is located in the built-up area
boundary of Hanlon Arden on a northern
section of the high street this slide
shows the application site edged in red
the site is partly within the home
Leonarda and conservation area which is
defined by the pink line the building is
a significant non designated heritage
asset within the conservation area the
application site includes a beech tree
which is sited close to the western
boundary and indicated by the green
circle this benefits from a tree
preservation order there are several
great to list of buildings across the
highway to the east and to the south of
the site the site is bound by
residential units to the north and west
with a solicitor's office abutting the
southern boundary this is an application
for full planning permission for a rear
extension and alterations to the
existing building to provide for
additional residential units a total of
10 units would be provided this block
plan indicates the proposed extent of
the rear extension shown here a new
access onto the high streets would also
be provided along with a driveway and
parking for 15 cars
this slide shows in more detail the
proposed hips and flat roof extension
the proposed access driveway and parking
area to the rear and amenity area would
also be provided to the south of the
parking area the proposed ground floor
plans on the left-hand side of the slide
showed the 11 point 2 meter long
extension and the alterations to the
existing building the proposed first
floor plan is shown on the right-hand
side of the screen this light slide
shows the proposed second floor
extension and reef plan a large expanse
of flat roof is proposed along with
Reef lies along the side elevations all
rear-facing units feature either a
terrace area or balcony this slide shows
the existing front and rear extent
elevations on the left hand is the
existing elevations on the right hand
are the proposed elevations this slide
shows the existing and proposed northern
side elevations showing the total 11.2
meter where extension which would be
visible within the conservation area the
hip reef projection with the slightly
grayed out gable projection is also
visible and then the additional
fenestration is shown this slide shows
the existing and proposed southern
elevations the 10 meter hip brief
extension along with the additional 1.2
meter gable projection is also visible
this photo shows the frontage of the
site to envy it from the north along the
high street the existing building is
raised up from the highway to the front
with open space to the front and side
for context Ladas Lister's is visible on
the left-hand side of the photo with
residential properties on Beechcroft
on the right-hand side the proposed
extension would be visible within this
gap the access would also be sited on
the left-hand side of the site this
photos taken further south along the
high street looking back to the site the
existing access drive for this listed is
visible on the left-hand side
the prized access would replace the
steps visible in the frontage of the
photo along with the pin and grits in
the driveway would also cut through
between the building and the lime tree
right this photo showed the rear
elevation of the building the rear of
the solicitor's office is visible on the
right-hand side of the photo with the
side elevation of numbers five and six
Beechcroft on the left-hand side the
extension would be sited on the grass
area here this photo is taking panning
around to the south to show more of the
rear elevation of the office and facing
towards the listed buildings the access
drive would cut through this part of the
site this face has taken from the rear
again now panning around to the north
facing the rears of numbers five and six
beach croft the host building an
existing wall are visible on the right
hand side this photo is taken panning
further around to face north the
bungalow which is visible is number
eight Beechcroft
while the rear elevation in gardens of
numbers five and six Beechcroft are
visible on the right hand side just to
clarify there are updates noted within
the update sheet in relation to
third-party responses an updated
ecological survey and impact on trees on
site officer recommendation is to refuse
application for full Planning Commission
for the reasons and notes which can be
found on pages 43 to 44 of the agenda
with the exception of suggested reason
number 5 due to the addition of a
revised ecological survey and mitigation
measures Thank You Jaime thank you very
much ok sorry in my haste to get out my
previous disclosure of interest I
admitted to announce that I actually
know the applicant we used to play rugby
together at all bit 10 years ago I
haven't seen or spoken to him for 7
years I am here with an open mind let me
tell you have to see on here but I
thought I better make that declaration
now great
so we're not going to hear from the town
council councillor David Tomlinson and
councillor David Broadbent you have
three minutes to speak between you if
you wish I just let me know how you wish
to proceed before you start we are on
good Thank You chairman councillors and
thank you for hearing us today we were
not registered to speak and we've been
invited to do so now this is this
application is a second application the
first one being withdrawn because we did
actually object to that and we have
returned and no representation on this
one on reflection the council would like
to support this application principally
because it is going to make good use of
a building that is in considerable need
of repair maintenance and future
development I have read the report that
the planning officer has produced I have
not had time to prepare anything that I
can actually speak to other than that I
probably would take issue with a number
of the points that were raised a flat
roof is not a wrong way of putting a
roof on a building the man sods hide the
fact there's a flat roof there the flat
roof won't be seen from the street yes
the building that will be put in is
slightly larger than the existing
building yes it will be seen from the
north as you come into the high street I
don't know that it will be seen very
greatly from the south on the high
street
I stood there this morning and looked at
it the lime trees in leaf you probably
wouldn't see it with the lime tree there
the lime tree should remain and yes I
know the issues about that lime tree
there have been in the past there are
also issues about the number of trees
that have been taken down off that site
by sealing the applicant
as far as I can see there are few object
and ejections from the population and I
think this will be a good use of this
building it doesn't actually increase
the number of units over much but it
does provide good accommodation that is
lacking at the moment in Henley some of
the overlooking yes that is an issue but
the issue is already there Beechcroft is
a three-story building though the some
of the flats are three storey buildings
so I suspect the bungalow can be
overlooked from those flats
I have no direct knowledge I suspect
that if the flats chose to look into the
back of numbers five and six that could
happen - it can also happen now from the
existing building there is an extension
of the third storey give it with a flat
roof dormer so I I I don't think I could
say any more we would like to support
this this application thank you very
much would you like are there any
questions thank you very much so there
are no objectors registered to speak
we're going to hear from the applicants
agent Jane Cashmore and the applicant
Greg white welcome back could you let me
know as well how you wish to share the
the three minutes yeah I think Greg's
going to do the first section which is
probably about 30 seconds then I'll just
follow on for the rest
okay so I'll let you know when does 30
seconds left thank you a good evening
chair and members the architect and I
have worked with Charlotte over 10
months providing substantial reductions
to the scheme the hopefully show on the
screen behind you we feel that we've
arrived a viable scheme that warrants
approval the first three refusal reasons
are entirely subjective the tree and the
so the reason
the tree reason in contra to
professional tree advice I've received I
have liaised with counselor Thirlwall
and the parish counseled you in the
process
neither of them object and in counselor
while supporting the welcome improvement
to this vacant site the report before
you is very detailed but I do need to
draw your attention to some factual
inaccuracies which have important
implications for the suggested reasons
for refusal firstly the report states
that views of the site are clearly
visible from high street and into it
from nearby vantage points the site
would only be clearly visible from high
street even then the extension sits
behind the existing building there are
no other public vantage points where it
would be clearly visible secondly the
report suggests the studies could be
used as bedrooms this is not agreed the
studies don't meet the necessary space
standards for single bedroom set out and
the technical housing standards thirdly
the report quotes of garden amenity
being unacceptable and refers to
guidance in meeting housing needs
however that guidance explicitly states
for the avoidance of doubt these do not
apply to flatted development these are
flats not houses whereas the policy
basis that the space which is in fact
larger than the quoted 180 square meters
is insufficient for the development
fourthly the rear windows and balconies
live 14 metres from the closest point of
the garden of number 8 extending your
home says minimum separation distances
should be 13 metres so why is a 14 meter
separation unacceptable fifthly
are tree specialists advisors there will
not be harm to important trees the tpo
will benefit from a net gain in its
rooting environment it's already
surrounded by non-permeable bitumen the
no dig levels can be provided by
condition we've carried out drastic
revisions to the scheme over the last 10
months we've removed extensions from
each side of the building remove three
detached cottages removed a detached
coach house reduce the height of the
rear extension twice and revised the
hard standing to ensure the existing
gardens to the front and side are
retained if you are not minded to grant
permission this evening
then given the subjectivity of the
reasons for refusal and our concerns
about the accuracy of the content of the
report 30 seconds we would request that
at the very least the applications
deferred to allow correction of these
details and would request you visit the
site of surrounding area but it's our
firm view that the implement that the
development warrants approval based on
the information already provided just
one brief comment on the update sheet in
relation to the CP re comments my view
on reading those is that they are
comments rather than an objection
outright thank you very much I'm going
to start off with some questions about
your I think it was 5 points you
disagreed with in the report ok we go
over the individually what was number
one again number one was that the report
states that the site would be clearly
visible from high street okay so I
didn't have an issue with that number
two number two was reference to the use
of studies as bedrooms okay yes thank
you
and number three specifically the flats
and amenity space which which reference
you referring to there which which
policy are you quoting from when it
specifically says this doesn't apply to
flatted residences so in the new report
on page 38 of your agenda when it talks
about provision of amenity for future
occupants it talks about supplementary
policy cs9 with meeting housing needs
and then the next paragraph goes on to
talk about the development comprises two
two-bedroom dwellings and etc these
aren't dwellings they're flats and
meeting housing these which sets minimum
garden sizes okay the 14 the next one
before the 14 meter separation distance
wasn't there something about change in
levels and that change in levels say the
exacting that's all I can ask that in
technical questions and the final point
about the tree
we our officers are saying that the the
the latest explanation they were they
received didn't didn't convince them
have you got any comments on that yeah
because of the levels yes I mean there's
been a lot of toing and froing between
the applicants tree expert and WI are
fora culturalist they have provided some
extracts of sections that provided
details of no dig that there will be no
ground disturbance that sell websites on
top on top of that there is a small
layer and then resin bonded gravel on
the top this isn't going to result in
some steep driveway which cars will be
unable to drive up and it's very typical
in their experience that this can be
dealt with through condition okay thank
you any other questions
catch the bombs in the ward members
comments have been reduced the
percentage she's a big building so if
you look at the top right-hand slide on
the screen there actually let's look at
the bottom bottom picture on the screen
you can see the the main building the
section to the right hand side is
existing the section of green to the
left is proposed concerns the resident
is raised as the single coach house due
to its impact on privacy it's well it
was being it was part of the original
scheme it's that little red area on the
top right but it's been removed
correct concern is a footpath diagonally
opposite I think you seem to know that
so we can go into that later on any
other questions
okay thank you very much and cancel a
third well can't be here today but he
has asked me to read out statement so I
will I'm forgive me I haven't read this
before so it's coming straight at you
chairman and members of the committee
first of all my apologies for not being
present this evening but unfortunately
the timing of this meeting clashed with
me being out of the country as you are
already aware the application concerns a
late 19th century unlisted detached
building at the north end of the high
street in Henley on the site is partly
within the conservation area but not
within the Greenbelt since a housing
association sold off this building it
has slowly started to deteriorate and
not offering a welcome approach to
henlon the scheme before you has emerged
to be an excellent proposal in relation
to previous withdrawn schemes which
would have cramped too much
accommodation on the site even though
the existing building is not listed it
is still part of the build history of
the town the proposal recognises this in
such a way that the existing building
will be preserved in appearance the
extension to the building will follow
and complement the current architectural
design of the original building which is
key as the original building is within
the conservation area at the time of
writing I am aware that the planning
officers still have a number of
concerns with this proposal namely trees
I'm aware that a report has been said to
the planners which ensures that the tree
with a tpo is protected during the build
period residential amenity there is some
concern with regards to loss of privacy
in some neighboring two-story properties
the proposal would be no similar to a
neighbor being able to see into next
door's garden in traditional
semi-detached houses the developers do
recognize this with the introduction of
1.8 meter high of Paik glass screams on
the balconies protected species I
understand that further work is being
undertaken with more surveys one at dawn
and two it does to confirm their
findings as this work is underway and if
at the date of this meeting the final
report is not received and hopefully
were you to decide to grant that it
would be subject to the findings of the
said report we have an update on that
heritage assets character the current
building will be preserved and therefore
will still reflect the build history of
the high street there is a question over
the bulk of the extension and a view
offered by the proposal as you approach
the site from the north of the town some
of the mass of the extension will be
hidden by number five feet rot
this can be compared to the court house
behind the old police station which has
a similar visibility issue from the high
street due to its height this proposal
complements the original house and
recognizes its architectural style it is
thankful thankfully not over development
of the site the scheme will also deliver
to two-bedroom flats and eight
one-bedroom flats which will allow young
people to get an entry into the property
market in an expensive and highly sought
after location I hope the committee will
be able to support this application and
ensure that this boarded up I saw is
brought back into use that will satisfy
a need within Henley so that's from
councillor thir well and now we go to
our technical questions Karen Richards
are we ready good and I have a question
about the our 1 & 2 bird needs in the
districts we have a policy that requires
us to produce a certain amount of one
and two bad properties are we meeting
that remind me what that need is cuz I
remember something head and are we
meeting that need out and if not how far
short are we sorry chairman we don't
have this sort of numbers the needs
generally addressed in terms of
percentages a certain percentage of new
development would be one to bed whatever
with the development of this size we
don't apply those percentages because
the development is too small to
reasonably apply it that's the only
answer I can give you I'm sorry we apply
that percentage across all the housing
requirement that we have as a district
then when we do percentages for one or
two beds are it is in our core strategy
but it's not in my head
well one bed sees five to ten percent
and two beds is thirty five to forty
percent of the total thank you any other
questions
cancer bars I don't know it's a question
or not was German but I would question
why I would like a site visit okay well
if if we wait to discussion any other
technical questions counselor Beechcraft
which is an opposite forward house I
mean I just can't see that from a site
visit which I actually did today just to
make this was an assessment of the wider
character of the area so looking at the
building plots surrounding that site so
the proposal would create a building
which would be disproportionately larger
than the character of the area and the
the size of the building certainly along
that side of the high street okay I'm
gonna ask a question I'm overlooking a
lots been said that actually you can
overlook these properties already what's
the difference in in your opinion what
are we looking at the difference from
what why you know why we're so different
in terms of the assessment on number
eight Beechcroft which is the bungalow
here we're looking at obviously a eleven
point two meter
building it's gonna be eleven point two
meters closer to that boundary so the
distance
is reduce down to 14 meters separation
distance to the decide boundary with
that property looking at the separation
distances that we require in extending
your home planning advice night for a
three story building we would be looking
for 16 meters and with any significant
change in levels the minimum separation
distance increases by two meters for
every meter so and that's to the is that
the distance to the property or to the
garden so the 14 meters is measured from
the nearest point of the extension to
the the garden area to the boundary and
that's all we've got in our policy
recommendation and the 16 meters you
mentioned well in terms of looking the
windows overlooking neighbors we would
be looking for at least 30 meters for a
three-story building that's again that
we would be looking at the because of
the change in ground level we'd be
looking to increase them okay and on 5 &
6 or similar issues in terms of the
impacts on 5 & 6 the extension to the
balcony would actually be located less
than 6 meters from the boundary to these
properties so although an opaque glazed
section is proposed to the side
elevation they would certainly be
overlooking possible don't in directly
into the garden areas okay I'm keeping
going so I'm just going to go although
this is the same ones I went over with
the agent amenity space not being an
issue for for flatted residences we've
got any comments on that in terms of the
residential amenity we would be looking
to ensure that sufficient I mean it's he
was provided sort requires but if you
notice the suggested reason for feel it
doesn't actually include the amenity
areas it is something which has been
highlighted in the report okay we're
making on issue is that we're looking to
we're looking for good development we're
looking for high quality development and
this proposal doesn't provide high
quality about
because it doesn't provide amenity space
you haven't got a reason for refusal we
don't think we could make it stand up
come appeal but nevertheless it's
leading to poor quality development
because of the the shortfall in amenity
space Thank You councillor Richards take
you back to fusion spacing and what have
you there's only one letter objection
that's been receive from members of
public and that was for a number of
thirty-one rather than a break kid have
you done an assessment on how far away
number 31 is from the building do they
fit within that 30 meter 16 meter
whichever wanting
yes we have assessed that and in the
report on page 38 the distances that
have been quoted are approximately 23
meters from the rear boundary of their -
and raised Avenue to the proposed
development okay cancer åkesson and we
are talking about not semi-detached
houses and I think you know quite
frankly I just cannot understand the
resistance tools we have okay remember
we're on questions right now if you
focus in more you see the vertical items
there are a good number of those more
than you'll see their lesser size they
are all white drain pipes it looks like
something from the Space Age and that is
awful in the area I fall in line with
councillor Barnes suggestion that in
order for members to be satisfied okay
counselor
this is quest site visitors necessary
okay well I've ceased to trust you
George
are there any other technical questions
to the officer no okay thank you then
we're gonna go to bed
George if you want to make that proposal
again we could do it you want to side
with it we've gone to debate we've gone
to debate unless you want any more
technical questions now it's all a
matter distance and appearance that we
want to save the building the board
member is supportive the parish council
was and not as far as I'm concerned if
decision because so you're proposing a
side visit okay great okay we're gonna
have a vote on that unless they're
almost to talk about that no okay so
we're gonna have a vote on do we have a
site visit all those in favor of a site
visit
all those again staged about three games
okay so no sign visit can we start
debate any questions councillor Giles I
agree that poser which looks to have
some smaller sized flats a very positive
one particularly in a place like Ken
Leonarda because I think there is a
noticeable lack of small property this
site have reminds me a little bit of the
hotel divan application I mean this
isn't of course a listed building but it
is and it's said to be not a significant
non designated heritage asset and I
agree with that and it's an important
three Road in the district I think it's
a road this road through honey nod and
gets it a lot of it draws a lot of
attention and it's it gets compliments
because of its heritage and actually I
think in places and actually I think
next door to this building is an example
of it it has been spoilt in places by
insensitive development and I think as a
district we want to be really careful
and mindful about that for me I think
there's there's a lot of potential here
to have some flats that offer something
to there but I'm not convinced this is
quite right and I would really like this
committee to get this right and and we
did that successfully without Oh divan
so there was an acknowledgement there
that maybe a an end which wasn't totally
subservient could still be in keeping
and we managed that with some further
tweaks and working on it but it took a
number of goes and I'm not convinced
where we're at all there yet I certainly
don't say that the previous applications
and the minimizations are in any way
relevant whatsoever this is not about
comparing bad with less bad it's about
is it right and I actually think this is
a really well reasoned report because if
you actually look at the I think
particularly the for the three first
reasons this isn't a finely balanced
consideration therefore there's three
strongly given reasons and I think if I
think one of the most important things
to understand about this site is its
raised levels
so that makes all of the impact more
significant than just looking at the
base measurements because as soon as
that is a raised level everything behind
it and next to it is it has more of an
impact and I think then if we turn the
if we if I could just see the back view
of the house what you've got to remember
is this is an extension which is going
to be bigger than this and those tall
that's huge it's it's a huge extension
to put on the back of there and I think
we have to take notwithstanding the fact
I appreciate that we have certain
properties who haven't specifically
objected in terms of their neighboring
amenity but but that's not the point
where that to protect those people
whether or not they have the ability to
object or I've seen the site notice and
actually we have a clear recommendation
that for a number of properties it would
result in an inadequate level of privacy
and I think we ought to take that
seriously I feel quite satisfied that
actually the bulk of that extension how
big it is you know and the way the roof
is designed so it's it's not breaking it
up in any way it breaks up that openness
that's there and I think we need to be
really careful about what we do with
Hanley high street so for me I also
think the fact that we haven't yet had
proper reassurance about trees and again
they are an extremely attractive feature
on Hanley high street I just think we
can do a lot better and bearing in mind
it's not a finely balanced conclusion
from officers they they have real
concerns on a large number of fronts I
think the safest thing to do is refuse
the application and then hope that the
applicant comes back with something
which is much more suitable much more in
keeping that we feel much more
comfortable with because this is about
having good good quality development not
one where people have cramped him and
hemmed in you know that we're really
happy is a good reuse of this site and
I'm sure it's achievable but I don't
feel it's there so I would propose to
refuse the application okay councillor
Richards thank you chair and one of the
points that Cancer Jones made was not
much not considering but
in her opinion the fact that the
original plans have gradually been
reduced to this
you know we're comparing bad with less
bad isn't a material consideration was
to a degree I agree with that I think
it's important to note inand something
that appears to being overlooked is the
fact that the the agent and the
applicant have worked with the council
and with both a parish and with the ward
member to get to a point where both
parish and ward member are in support so
I think that shouldn't be overlooked
particularly given we apply the Localism
Act to a lot of what we do it's
important that they have their say in
terms of the actual building yes it is a
larger building but is it demonstrable
improvement to the back end of that that
site not to mention an improvement to
the streets given we currently have and
I don't know how long it's been boarded
up certainly for as long as I can
remember he's been boarded up it will be
a significant improvement to the street
scene as well in my opinion I actually
have no particular issue with this and
if we were moving in the direction of
granting I'd be more than happy to
support that Thank You councillor Barnes
remember we've already had a proposal
well it's all to do with distances and
the location and we do need these type
of flats that's what people want it
would say the old building I would have
preferred to gone and had a look at it
to see if you know it was how I feel
like trying to support it but
unfortunately I don't know any more
facts at the moment but I think what
cancer Richard said was his right thank
you
I don't I I just okay cancer I can
that is not I think about it and of
course perhaps this Canada yeah up to I
think we begin this month cancer child
subservient it fails to form a
subservient addition to this significant
building within a conservation area and
that's and it says I therefore consider
the rear extension would not be
sufficiently subordinate to the host
building and due to the views possible
and it's been accepted by the applicant
that there would be clear views of this
from the high street that it would not
be it would not preserve or enhance the
character of the heritage as we
obviously have a disagreement here I
think we just leave it at that we have
different opinions I agree with with a
lot of what people have said I think
it's an obvious improvement this is this
is a property that needs that needs
something due to it the drawings I've
seen a definite improvement and I think
the volume be it not subservient or
otherwise and and the fact that it
impacts somewhat on the conservation
area doesn't worry me but what does
worry me is the impact on neighbors and
and because of that their issue about
the impact and neighbors and a question
over the the trees although I have heard
what counsel earther well and and the
Town Council have said and that that
carries a lot of weight
it really does I'm inclined I'm inclined
I would I would definitely have
supported it if it wasn't for this
overlooking issue so I'm going to second
Molly's proposal that we follow the
officer recommendation and and refused
this and my grounds are mainly on the
overlooking I think we'll have a I have
a vote on that now unless anyone really
wants to speak on that so if we vote on
that proposal before us
to refuse the application all those in
favor of refusing the application please
though now all those in favor of no
sorry
all those against refusing the
application and no extensions so that
fails is there an alternative proposal
catch the bombs I will although I would
have preferred you looked at it I would
propose the disapproved with the correct
conditions as far as I can see it will
save the building there is a big
extension we'd need something is inside
a job look at it it's a mess so we have
a proposal on the grounds that it will
it will be an improvement in in in the
look of the building the boot and the
flats will be needed in the and the
flats are needed by community and as far
as I'm concerned it is partly in the
conservation area will improve the
conservation area then if he started to
do so actually improvement to the
conservation air because of that yeah if
we're gonna go against offices so do we
have a seconder councillor Vaudrey okay
could you happy with those reasons I
don't have a with those reasons good
conditions obviously materials and to be
agreed I think will delegate those two
offices in in in cooperation with the
chair I'm sure that we could leave the
Chairman to do that okay and all other
conditions
to be clear what committees what are
they saying it doesn't matter or Oman it
the officers gotta make certain that is
not endangered by the development that
okay we'll get a little more debate
malli the problem that you've got
Council Atkinson is that you you've been
clearly told by officers that they do
don't feel this such as this proposal
and the current information they have
satisfies them in terms of trees so what
I think would be more appropriate if you
are concerned about it that issue and I
say you certainly ought to be is that as
it was suggested by the applicant the
matters deferred for further information
to be provided about that and for that
to be to be to be sorted out properly
because at the moment what you are
basically authorizing is an application
which your officers are telling you puts
in danger trees which are protected and
they're not satisfied they will be
protected I think anybody who's been
accustomed to the system knows in
grunting the application that officers
are satisfied no danger exists to the
tree with the can hang on thank you can
I can we have some comment on that I I
would like to see I would like to see
that that we ensure that this tree it's
just one tree are we talking about is is
protected and can we can we condition so
that you know the the application fails
if your if officers are not satisfied
that can go ahead German in resolving to
grant permission you're saying that this
development can be take can be carried
out and you're satisfied that the tree
will not be harmed or or it can be
carried out without harming the tree
you're saying that one your grand
planning permission so if you are if you
wish to proceed and to grant permission
then the way to achieve that is to defer
it letters to investigate further
from the tree let's look at
okay I got that now deal with it and
then come back to you we've had us that
we've had a proposal in a second as I
believe we have to take the vote unless
the proposal with jaws which I would ask
you to do at this point second would you
withdraw you're seconding no okay have a
word I just gonna say what about this
treating what I'm entirely happy for the
officers to resolve but I would point
out that the last paragraph on page 39
about the tree does say a tree survey
has been submitted so I think that works
would not impact the tree and any any
more than existing Hart standing has and
there's a no dig construction method
that's been proposed so given we have a
no dig and given that there is a tree
survey that says that there's no damage
is for officers to then confirm that and
okay so we've also got on the update
speak sheets specifically says that
officers are not satisfied with emotion
provide that might be the case but they
they have an opportunity to go through
this approval will have an opportunity
to go and satisfy themselves and put an
interruption to I think you're making
the assumption that can be done and I
think that the whole point is that we
don't know that it can be done that's
why it's a condition but you can't
condition something which is impossible
if it turns out to be impossible
Cara Giles I think the problem is
councillor Richards is that if you grant
the application as it is you're
basically saying we are satisfied that
what you're proposing at the moment in
terms of the build we don't think as a
committee there is a risk to the trees
now that is not the officers advice they
say they're not currently satisfied in
terms of what's been put forward in
terms of the plans as they currently
stand
Douce if they're not yet satisfied that
those do cook cover the trees so the
point is I think if you grant it what
you're saying is then what you you
disagree with the officers and that's
fine that's good conduct committee but I
can't I can see the arguments say with
it
about a condition is it because if those
a condition officers would say this
isn't going to be granted because we
don't think it is satisfied this is
complicated
I'm going to get back to officers on
this because I'm surprised though we
can't put in a condition that this this
has to you know this has to be
satisfactory otherwise that the planning
application can't go ahead if you're
telling me categorically we can't do
that that's fine that's what I'm looking
for but I thought we could we're not
satisfied
based on the current information because
of the gradient within the sites that a
noida construction can be carried out so
because of the change in level for
instance from the highway to the front
no and so the technical aspects what I'm
asking is that we can we not can't we
make a decision here that says if you
cannot comply with a no dig construction
or some way of not harming that tree
during construction then you you cannot
implement the planning application if
condition' said work cannot comment on
site until a satisfactory report has
been produced to demonstrate that a node
dig can be implemented then surely that
does exactly what we're trying to say
you cannot start construction until this
is satisfied it will if we're not
satisfied they can't start construction
therefore all bases covered and that
would be one of the conditions that we
could put forward in the proposal
conditions have to comply with a number
of tests I think I've mentioned it
already this evening we don't know
whether there might be a very large root
or a feeding route for the tree that
Charlotte pointed out just there that's
close to the surface if there's changing
levels and to create the driveway it's
necessary to excavate then it's
potentially possible that damage will be
caused to those roots that will kill the
tree
we can't know we can't condition a
permission that says you can only build
this if you if you can demonstrate to us
that the tree won't be harmed we're
granting permission we're saying we've
taken into account the impact on the
tree
you must take certain steps not to
damage it but it may not be possible to
take certain steps to get the vehicles
over the roots of that tree and make the
angle of approach that the local highway
authority requires there are a number of
technical things that come together okay
I think we've got know several times
there I I really would like us to defer
but I cannot make you can't but I think
that the sensible thing here is to defer
to get more information on the trees and
then bring it back to committee but it
needs the proposer to agree to that
no no council actions that we're looking
at trying to get this removed so that we
can defer it yeah okay I would strongly
urge members to vote against this so
that we can then vote to defer it so we
can get the information okay but we're
gonna go ahead okay with conditions
delegated officers we are now voting to
grant this application all those in
favor all those against
okay this committee has resolved to
grant planning application for 18 where
are we
18:01 four five six full thank you
and we're going to go into the next
application
well I think we need some shopping
application 1801 768 for now Emily's
hunt hall lane Welford on Aven okay
please okay yeah I think we got that
yeah okay thank you now Stuart to our
flattish please Thank You chair good
evening this is a full planning
application for the demolition of an
existing bungalow and outbuildings and
the erection of a new detached
replacement dwelling and garage here we
see the application site is on Hunter
Lane accessed off Barton Road within
well for Nathan this is illustrated by
the black dots here on your screens here
we see an aerial view of the application
site itself signified by an arrow
pointing towards it the site is in an
area of open countryside outside of the
built-up area boundary yeah here we can
actually see a submit this was the
submitted site location plan which shows
the application site in more detail one
can see the partial extent of the
applicant land ownership here signified
within the blue lion agency here of the
wider farmstead here we see five barns
immediately to the north of the
application site but still within the
app container ship these were recently
granted prior approval for conversion to
residence with dwellings in all in the
17th of August last month immediately to
the north of these barns you can see a
site here that is the subject of a live
clan application at the time of speaking
that has yet to be determined this
application is for the demotion of that
bungalow and erection of up to 15 to
Wellings
the bill to pay a boundary for well foot
runs along the boundary as you see here
on a screen so this is a this
application site is in an area
considered to be open countryside here
we can see the submitted post slightly
late site plan where one can see the
footprint outlined of the existing
existing bungalow with what are
permitted development rights
extensions to the rear and to the size
one can also then see in the dark gray
what was actually proposed to be the
dwelling in addition to the garage here
to the north east of the site what can
obviously the building's been slightly
opposed to be slightly reorient ators as
well this is currently on here we see
the first Northwest and Southwest
elevations are submitted here we can see
the south east and northeast elevations
and here are the post elevations of the
proposed garage we now have some photos
of the existing building itself here we
can actually see the bungalow we're
standing on the existing driveway
looking at the West elevation the
principal elevation as we look at it at
the front door here we can standing now
in the rear of the garden in the
southeast corner looking back on the
side and rear the Christine bungalow
here we can also see a small part here
one of the cultural buildings which I
mentioned earlier which are outside of
the application site but are within the
applicant ownership which where I looked
at the prior approval conversion here we
are now stood on the same spot looking
southeast woods towards the surround
the countryside that border the
application site and here it's a example
of a mobile home that is opposite the
application sites on the west side of
hunter Lane that is my presentation
chair I would further members to the
update sheet for all relevant updates to
things to say really this provided by
the by the applicants myself and the
agent acts on their path have had some
correspondence relating to revised plans
after I share with them that there is a
recommendation of refusal the case
officer produce a big apartment be the
agents produced to revisions essentially
which weren't my consideration
it was my determination that neither
these revisions were sufficient to
overcome the reasons for refusal and
consequently the original plans are the
ones put before you tonight's chair the
recommendation is to refuse the
application for the reasons to sell on
page 57 of your agenda thank you thank
you and we're going to hear from the
parish council councillor Simon Carter
good evening as you note three minutes
and will tell you half a minute before
good evening everybody
as you've seen there the existing
building is a 1960s poor quality no EPC
rating very tired for the building the
proposed development the applicant
actually has worked very well with the
parish council and in fact the ward
member and tried to do the same in the
officer the officers just explained why
some resubmitted plans weren't accepting
but actually did reduce the bridge
height to something like seven and a
half meters from eight meters so as you
saw from the outline designs it's
actually sort of built into the roof
line and in policy terms this is a
replacement it's not a new building
open countryside and then the NDP policy
85 a day is 10 paragraph that's F so the
define what can go on this is a
replacement develop dwelling and
although not specifically referenced in
85 the development of existing
properties and even their replacement
where deemed appropriate for sort of
environmental reasons was always part of
the NDP development sort of
considerations and I did actually write
that so that was our thinking in
addition the house is in a similar
situation
in addition that house is in a similar
situation on the edge of the village
inside or outside the daughter barrier
boundary could certainly have an
urbanizing effect however in this case
given it to one for on one for one
replacement its wood frame it's wood
clad in design we do not believe this is
urbanizing that particular part of the
village regarding housing mix it's
already been mentioned that the adjacent
property which is in the ownership of
the applicants actually and it's
actually forests our NDP policy that
actually requests or looks for
additional buildings provision of
housing for all the residents which in
turn styles including bungalows in fact
there are five bungalows been erected or
given permission on the 17th of August
in the next-door property so actually
the net position of this being removed
because that was a serious consideration
for us you know we're still actually
benefiting from four votes the proposed
property actually is a very high quality
very highly sustained well the
insulation levels proposed are actually
twice the building regulations you know
this is actually designed to be you know
bit of an exemplar in that sort of space
so it is going to be a very sustainable
building and you know on plan balance
the
30 second thank you thank you had
questions thank you very much
and now we have the applicant yes mr.
and mrs. Hockaday hello you've got three
minutes do you want to each speak or
okay lovely thank you so you've got ask
okay so you have three minutes and I'll
tell you when you and and also I think
it would be appropriate to refer back to
one of the earlier aerial photographs as
well assuming closer because it shows
the application site in the context of
its mature hedging which I think he's
relevant so if you could do that for
that during the presentation thank you
regulations grad sauce eating a soda
fever you also incorporated the proposal
is therefore highly sustainable in both
location terms of magics built for these
quotes are not addressed by the case of
step another frame dwelling is proposed
incorporating carefully chosen handmade
bricks natural clay have roof tiles o
timber boarding and open windows and
ease detailing the data summary is
concerning phenomena with many of the
traditional buildings in wealth Jonathan
but also a countryside setting the
existing nineteen fifties both a totally
suburban in style with yellow brick
concrete roof tiles and two large white
QP pieces conservatory the scale design
and appearance of the proposed wedding
is not harmful to the character of the
area nor visibly intrusive house
learning would be an enhancement to this
part of the village the 10 acres of lab
which we owe to only even where we keep
our sheep is surrounded by the two
hedges which on hunt or later evergreen
and then for sticks to do that will take
shown on the slides there are also many
mature trees in our ownership which has
16 Weaver's at home and open the house
will sit well within its landscape
setting to demonstrate this point and
would like to point it to the cases
report on page 54 which clearly states
the proposed development impact on the
existing existing from relationship
point of view yet this and the designer
recommended reasons for refusal on page
53 wheels officer also refer to the diet
has been very nice
thank you very much any questions no
thank you
thank you very much oh yes so could we
have the picture that was referred to
the overview is something you'd like to
say that quality might be a bit blurred
apologies this is just a screenshot
really of what's an area like to make
which in terms of hunt or lane which you
could see if you zoomed on a picture and
if the officer showed a picture in his
report are these ever green hedges
they're 6 meters in height and there are
also trees on the other side of the lane
that are in our ownership so the
property is not visible at all it's only
visible from the current entrance and it
will be narrower than what is that's
plated okay thank you thank you there
are some biotech for quite a few photos
between little bit back I'm happy to
leave through the other than if that's
that's that's very helpful thinking
great thank you
you've seen it yep thank you you can
turn the mic up
technical questions oh I'm sorry yes
I'll stop here five don't worry
thank you this is a young couple who
were actually following their sheep they
lived up the road they had the land
ground there and the old lady days he
died and they obviously have taken over
the property so they'll be next to their
livestock they had some extensions or I
didn't know that they had but then they
had another extension approved and I did
go and see them and I said look all the
bungalows built in 1962 by this builder
haven't got foundations senior officer
said well a lot of them don't have
foundations and they looked at again and
then decided to go for a replacement
dwelling situation was that the
inspector well quit has always wanted
them 8.1 meters this was a little bit
above that and their fair dues they
changed a few things and as far as I'm
concerned it looks and the daily cash if
you like in the position there are
twenty-four caliban's on one side six
bungalows next to it I'm a planning
application just where that bungalow is
just only up above I will go through
that and in a moment when the
application was put out I briefly did
the caravans and two people were
concerned about the noise I did put a
note about environmental health and they
assured that times of working would be
yet at the right time not sort of
sapphic you know the proper times they
were concerned with that little lane
that you know they weren't going to get
up or whatever and in the respect of the
locals and nobody there really over
bothered the worst crimson concern with
the other applications on there but as
far as I'm concerned the CBRE
have made some comment and as you can
see that's where
the letters of objection have come from
his family have lived in the village
sometime late years a school governor a
lot to do with the village they will be
near their livestock and as far as I can
see with this environmentally friendly
house with all the slates and whatever I
I think it should be supporting in the
respect of the landscape in they do own
and it doesn't show you there that the
respite a substantial hedge on the right
side of where the red line is that where
the line comes down that could be
enhanced fairly easily in the distance
of the footpath is somewhere in the
region of 170 meters and that is behind
the hedge except there is one gate which
is obviously a little distance away
which you can see I think the idea
really of being in open countryside is
not relevant it is out of the village
boundary which isn't relevant in the
respect of a replacement dwelling but I
think I would like to go on to the two
pictures that I've got because I think
that's about my time if you I did give
you two pictures the points been paused
catch that one your time has been paused
we're looking for these pictures they
were
well I don't
okay well I think we have to live
without them if that's all right well
not really the point is if you go back
to the map then there we are if you put
the if you go put the arrow up to it a
bungalow there see that good that means
a bungalow there is a replacement
application in at the moment for a
replacement bungalow there and the
replacement bungalow is 15 houses out of
the village boundary and that is that
consultation at the moment I don't know
what the parish council said but I spoke
to the Louise Coleman who has been going
through this application 46,000 is
called the applicant has cost them to go
through and today senior officer here
was here that if we feel the only reason
for refusal is outside the village
boundary she did say that's the same
thing now that has got big houses only
10 to 14 meters from the footpath in
total open countryside which would be
very very detrimental to the area 36
what I'm saying is I had got a picture
of the four bedroom houses that we had
agreed to go on that side which was
substantially bigger than this
replacement dwelling I'm very disabled
oh there we are right now that is
closest of the footpath in open
countryside with both sides of the if
you look on the map open whereas this is
only on one side open and I see no
reason really why all the thought that
has gone into it and all the effort has
gone into it and for the safety of the
livestock and live I can trade that said
cash
location why we shouldn't support it
okay thank you and I'm quite happy to
answer any questions and I'm sorry that
it took so it's time to these are there
any questions from counselors no Thank
You counselor I'm sorry counselor the
consultation and today no videos that
myself and the case officer with the
senior office of their agreed that we
could refute it only on being outside
the village boundary okay thank you
that's too much simpler thank you any
other questions
no Thank You counsel about technical
questions okay debate in favor of the
application you did one answer question
okay okay I mean look because this is
things seem to be going backwards today
let's have that question answer please
germán this is an application for a
replacement dwelling we have policies in
our development plan but deal with
replacement dwellings that are outside
built-up area boundaries the approach to
replacement dwellings outside built-up
area boundaries is set out in your
report and what we're saying is that in
terms of size whether you look at the
existing bungalow and the proposed house
or whether you look at the existing
bungalow plus the extensions that could
conceivably be built on it versus the
proposed house the proposed house is
considerably larger it has considerably
more impact in the open countryside than
the current bungalow and that's the
basis for the the reason for refusal
chairman okay now we are going to debate
any question debate councillor Giles the
rationale for that policy of course is
because were there not already a
building on that site and one was
applying to put a building on the
outside the built-up area boundary you
know they would no doubt be restrictions
on that so what one is looking to do is
if there is going to be a replacement
dwelling it should be similar in terms
of size and proportion as to what is
currently there I think it's a lovely
design
I think positive potential is are
designed to be very in keeping in terms
of its materials no doubt a replacement
dwelling here is what is probably in
order given how the bungalow looks but
for me I don't see any difficulty in the
policy reasoning in the report which is
it is a significantly disproportionate
increase in terms of volume but also
height which i think is one of the big
issues so for me I think no doubt a
replacement dwelling is in principle
acceptable but it's just the specifics
of this particular proposal so I don't
see any reason not to support the
offices recommendation
that's a proposal
yes it can be yes well it is a very nice
building and we've heard a lot of
comments from the parish as well as the
counselor and the applicants that it is
it's not particularly viewable from
outside which which might overcome some
of the landscape issues that were
mentioned in the report but it doesn't
overcome that fundamental policy reason
of something being pretty much the same
size a replacement dwelling outside the
built-up area boundary being pretty much
the same size as the original dwelling
which this obviously isn't so I'm going
to second all those in favor of refusing
this application against refusing this
application please vote now yeah I don't
live this that far from here and I've
been down this road several occasions
I've been almost I think this thing that
surprised me most today as some would
want to build a house as nice as that in
that vacation when I say I mean I'm
brave and I'm sure you've done your due
diligence on it it is it is well
protected there are other houses that
have gone up around Wilford that are not
too similar in size and look and stature
so in many ways I know they're scattered
around but I think I don't think it's
out of place in Welford so I think to
cut to the chase I'm happy to propose
that we actually support this
application on the grounds I'm not very
good on the grounds but it's an
enhancement to the local area
I'm sure counsel which is much better
than if you have a second it and coming
up with all the good reasons that we
need for planning but I'm happy to
propose that we support this application
cutting it will enhance the local area I
will be looking for grants on this so
that's a start
Richard I'm quite have a second that I I
think I'm applying similar logic to the
previous application that when you
consider the local markets and apply
that to this clearly we have a support
from a ward member support from a parish
council and I think I actually put
material weight on further the Parish
Council have been inundated with
large-scale developments in their
village and have almost blanket refused
those and now they're actually very
supportive of something I think that
says a lot of for me that they would be
willing to support something I haven't
given the history in Welford also I
think the the design of the house the
scotland size scale etc and bulking mass
is not out of keeping with Welford and
in its location and on that basis I'm
quite happy to support to do so we have
various reasons for going against the
office design scale in keeping to
materials and insulation in terms of
insulation and I think that it's a fair
point specific location I mean I can for
me I was hesitating you know between
thorne against and I would be thinking
of it slope of it's a bit specific
litigation and these these fees these
reasons I was very specific to its
location in a place in the countryside
really it may be technically it open
countryside but it's very much not bring
members back to the wording of the
policy and ask them to address the
wording of the policy in there their
reasoning for for granting permission
the policy says where the existing
dwelling is not considered suitable for
retention the replacement dwelling will
be well sited in relation to the
existing
in buildings I think you've addressed
that not visually intrusive
I think you've addressed that and not
significantly larger than the dwelling
it replaces I are you satisfied that in
your view it's not significantly larger
than the dwelling it replaces I don't
think we can say that I don't think we
could say it's not significantly larger
than the 22 different places but I think
other other other aspects of this
application about where where it's cited
in relationship to the village chair
house mr. Walker for one clarification
my understanding was it was there was
that the dwelling and then there was
already other planning that could be
used to extend that existing dwelling
just not on the same footprint is that
correct and there is the potential under
permitted development to extend that
original dwelling and if that option is
exercised the existing dwelling will
still be substantially smaller than the
proposed dwelling and I can give you the
figures which are in the report if you
wish but it'll take me a moment to it is
subjective what is that so if the
wording is and it is in the opinion this
committee not substantially bigger than
the existing building and the other
planning permissions on this particular
site then I think we are addressing as
best we can those things that are that
are cited so that that would be part of
the 55 is a reasonable okay lovely so
we've got a proposal and a seconder okay
so all those in favor doing it their
conditions on this or will they just be
standard conditions
you could just delegate those stuff can
we tell the gate yeah by officers and
the chair thank you this which won't be
a king I think there might be some brace
please okay good so all those in favor
of granting this application please vote
now all those against an abstained
so this committee has resolved to grant
planning application 1801 seven six
eight and that's it do we have anything
else no as in business so we'll 26th of
September okay thank you very much